[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va parler aujourd'hui de
l'enfance de la jeunesse sont
particuliers dans les classes populaires
gersoise en effet fatima wa sac pour son
livre la puissance des mères ces
sous-titrés pour un nouveau sujet
révolutionnaire
je reçois également daniel picouly pour
son roman longtemps je me suis couché de
bonne heure c'est proust transposer dans
une cité de banlieue pas un garçon de 15
ans et enfin vincent cuvellier auteur
pour la jeunesse qui publie le plus
mauvais livres du monde
l'histoire d'un ado qui tombe sur un
très très mauvais roman et qui pire
encore tombe sur son auteur mais on
commence comme d'habitude pas notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle voici vos
réponses en images on commence par celle
de de fatima fatima ou à sac
ces deux garçons oui pas que vous
connaissez je pense quand on connaît
leur leurs visages s'agit de zyed benna
et bouna traoré morts le 27 octobre 2005
dans le cadre d'une intervention
policière
j'ai choisi cette image là pour parler
de la desenfant tease à sion de nos
enfants le fait que lorsque des enfants
meurent notamment dans le cadre d'une
intervention policière on ne considère
pas que ce sont des enfants
on considère qu'ils ont mérité de mourir
il n'avait pas circulé librement dans
l'espace public
il n'avait pas courir et finalement ils
n'avaient pas existé dans l'espace
public et à 7 des enfants tease à sion
répond une déshumanisation de leurs
parents on va rendre responsable de la
de la mort de leur enfant ils devaient
tenir leurs enfants ils ne devaient pas
les laisser circuler librement dans
l'espace public
ce sont des parents démissionnaires ce
sont des parents laxistes donc voilà
c'est laisser jeu
g
pour moi c'est une foule c'est une image
une photo qui est importante c'est aussi
l'illustration des luttes des quartiers
populaires quartiers populaires qu'on
envisage toujours dans dans la violence
mais en même temps dans une certaine
forme de passivité
ce qui s'est passé en 2005 c'est une
révolte populaire notamment des jeunes
de la jeunesse de ce pays qui s'est
rebellé que ces révoltés ont déjà pour
exprimer sa colère après que deux des
leurs soit mordant dans ces conditions
mais aussi pour pour dire qu'ils étaient
vivants qui le voilà qu'ils avaient
encore de l'espoir qu'il ne voulait pas
se résigner à au sort qu'on leur qu'on
leur réserve et donc c'est aussi pour
moi
voilà une illustration le symbole des
luttes des luttes des quartiers
populaires et les la puissance des mères
dont on va parler dans un instant
puisque c'est un le livre fait référence
également à ça vous avez choisi notre
image qui est celle d'un dragon on va le
voir ce dragon c'est la puissance de la
mer c'est exactement des maires au
pluriel puisque j'envisage ce sujet
politique au pluriel dans le cadre d'un
collectif oui le dragon parce que bon
déjà c'est une figure majestueuse
fantastique c c'est une
une figure qui n'existe pas donc et ça
je trouve qu'en terme de d'élargissement
des champs des possibles de lutte a
inventé il ya quelque chose là
d'intéressant puis c'est aussi une
figure populaire qui existent existe
partout dans le monde
en asie en afrique évidemment dans
l'occident estime à wes un canton comme
ce sujet politique active à partir d'un
terreau mais quand on dit d'une mère
qu'elle est à dragon c'est pas pour ses
pubs pour la complimenter c'est pas pour
lui faire plaisir au général ham alors
justement c'est pour rompre avec cette
cette représentation comme on a des
femmes qui sont qui sont stigmatisante
alors comme ont pu le faire les folles
de la place de mai et les folles de la
place vendôme dont je parle dans livre
donc des mères qui se battent pour leurs
enfants et qui ont renversé le stigmate
en se réappropriant cette injure qui est
faite aux femmes folles pour les chasser
de l'espace public de la même manière
voilà dragon match truc c'est encore une
fois c'est une figure magnifique
moi je trouve que pour les mères pour
incarner notre combat pour protéger nos
enfants pour et puis alors aussi pour
pour assumer peut-être cette part de feu
donc qui symbolise la colère moi je
trouve que c'est vraiment quelque chose
à explorer voilà en termes de
perspectives à venir
on en parle dans un instant daniel
picouly votre image à vous elle est
moins fantastique mois surnaturel sur
les réseaux sociaux
oui oui c'est à dire cet homme m'a
demandé ce qui avait fait basculer les
années 2000 je pense que ce sont les
réseaux sociaux basculer dans ce qui
peut avoir de positif on vient de parler
de cette puissance de dénonciation que
contient les réseaux sociaux beaucoup de
sujets qui auraient été ensevelies et y
compris ce qui se passe en banlieue où
ont émergé à travers à la fois des
photos et des films et les réseaux
sociaux la propagation de ces
informations là ça c'est là la dimension
quasi révolutionnaire
des réseaux sociaux qui met des gens
dans la rue et de l'autre côté il ya
ceux qui est pour moi le pire des
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire une espèce
de 2,2 frange permanente de calomnies de
dénonciation de ces dénonciations qui
colle à la peau indépendamment de la de
la justesse ou de goût de la vérité et
de l'emprise que ça peut avoir aussi
bien dans notre vie privée que dans la
vie publique et la vie politique quand
on pense aujourd'hui la force des
réseaux sociaux dans la communication
politique
on s'aperçoit que c'est un
bouleversement aujourd'hui parce qu' on
est loin de tout contrôle de tout
contrôle démocratique les réseaux
sociaux sont au sens propre une anarchie
bienfaisante ou malfaisants mais une
anarchie qui ne peut pas être compris
sauf dans des régimes totalitaires qui
parviennent en empêcher l'expression
voilà donc moi je trouve que ça c'est
rédhibitoire et moi j'essaie au maximum
de me tenir à l'écart des des réseaux
sociaux sur un espèce de néandertaliens
dans ce domaine là parce que j'y trouve
plus en tout cas pour moi de raison de
m'inquiéter que de raison d'espérer
vincent cuvellier sont pas les réseaux
sociaux mais ce sont des téléphones
portables un ensemble ça va un peu moi
je me promène beaucoup je remercie
nommément la rue dans la ville
je m'appelle déjà affirmé que des
visages baisser si on ajoute à ça les
oreillettes le masque les lunettes de
soleil si à la canicule
les gens sont complètement fermés
aujourd'hui demander un renseignement
dans la rue à quelqu'un ça devient
compliqué le téléphone portable iphone
est devenu un espèce de coach personnel
et je me demande quelle était sa veut
faire sur les enfants sur les jeunes sur
les ados c'est sa coupe en fait
complètement les ados ça mais d'un côté
le monde des jeunes et de l'autre côté
le monde des adultes on
par exemple moi quand j'étais gamin
quand je me faisais engueuler par mon
père en fait d'une confrontation où je
m'excuse et où je me discuter ou je
filais dans ma chambre et ce cas qu'elle
apporte aujourd'hui en fait il suffit
juste de regarder son portable pour
clore une programmation qui nous dérange
et je me demande vraiment comment mais
comment les gamins vont grandir avec ce
ce coach personnel en sexe et et si j'ai
choisi cet objet c'est tout simplement
parce que moi c'est un objet qui a une
influence vraiment dans ma vie de tous
les jours parce que je le subis
moi moi j'en ai pas j'aime pas ça etc
mais je veux subi je suis obligé de
vivre avec ça et ça prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur eh bien on commence
[Musique]
fatima boissac vous êtes donc l'une des
fondatrices du front de mer on en
parlera tout à l'heure mais là vous
venez de publier la puissance des mères
à la découverte
vous y raconter très bien quel point
quand on est maman et quand vous l'avez
été une première fois mais aussi comme
vous l'avez été une seconde phase on se
sent investi d'une à un pouvoir immense
vous aviez vraiment la sensation d'être
tous pour vos enfants et en même temps
presque rien alors pourquoi ce presque
rien oui a donc un j'ai effectivement
vécu un sentiment paradoxal c'est à dire
que le fait de porter un enfant
évidemment ça ça donne une certaine
forme de puissance le fait de d'enfanter
le fait d'allaiter aussi enfin le fait
d'allaiter son enfant et de pouvoir le
nourrir quasi exclusivement ou
exclusivement pendant les premiers mois
de sa vie sans sans l'aide du système
capitaliste de l'industrie
agroalimentaire etc et donc de devenir
finalement une référence ultime pour
pour son enfant ça ça donne un pouvoir
une puissance immense et dans le même
temps dès l'accouchement réalité donc
dès le fait d'être placé en position
inconfortable pour accoucher de manière
à faciliter le confort des obstétriciens
dès ce moment là on est en quelque sorte
dépossédé de son de son pouvoir on ne
décide de rien ou alors simplement de
voilà de la marque du tee shirt de la
couleur des chaussettes mais de pas
grand chose en tout cas on ne décide pas
du sort de ces enfants on n'est pas
autorisée on n'est pas légitime pour
pour le faire et donc ça commence dès
l'hôpital est en réalité ça ça se
prolonge tout au long de la vie de
l'enfant que ce soit à l'école dans
l'est dans l'espace public dans les
différentes institutions
les maires ne sont pas considérés comme
étant responsable du sort de leur enfant
en tout cas pas considérés comme étant
légitime pour donner leur avis politique
sur la société dans laquelle on entend
dire leurs enfants vous expliquez que au
fond le corps médical d'abord puis les
industriels puis les médias puis le
ministre de l'intérieur puis le ministre
de l'éducation nationale prenne
vos enfants sous leurs ailes et
ils vont s'occuper de leur destin à
votre place à ce poids là vous avez ce
sentiment de dépossession alors pas
simplement de dépossession de d'être de
le sentiment d'être et c'est pas qu'un
sentiment c'est assez objectif d'être
stigmatisés en tant que parents par
exemple l'utilisation de cette
expression qui est le parents
démissionnaires de la seine-saint-denis
le parents laxistes avec des injonctions
paradoxales qui consiste à considérer
que le parent est démissionnaire et
qu'il donc il est laxiste qu'il ne
s'occupe pas bien de ses enfants qu'il
ne les tient pas dans les appartements
exigus
comme je disais tout à l'heure par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé au
lendemain de la mort de zyed et bouna et
dans le même temps considère que ce sont
des parents qui sont envahissants qui
inculque comme ça à leurs enfants des
cultures une religion obscurantistes des
langues et des sous l'angle des
dialectes et donc ils prennent trop de
place dans la vie de leur enfant il
faudrait qu'ils laissent davantage le
choix leur enfant pour tout ce qui
concerne leur culture la religion etc
des injonctions qui sont qui sont
paradoxales et qui tendent à déposséder
le parent de la responsabilité pleine et
entière qu'il a 2 et qu'elle a de ses
enfants alors dans dans les quartiers
populaires où je milite beaucoup parfois
il ya des parents qui sont qui sont
considèrent qu'ils ont le sentiment que
leurs enfants ne leur appartiennent pas
alors nos enfants ne nous appartiennent
jamais mais en réalité on en a la
responsabilité pleine et entière est par
exemple on confie nos enfants à
l'éducation nationale on ne fait que les
confier certains parents aujourd'hui ont
l'impression que leur qui n'ont pas la
responsabilité pleine et entière de leur
enfant et qu'au contraire
l'institution les laisse s'en charger à
16h30
en espérant que de ses heures 30 à 22
heures voilà il fasse pas trop n'importe
quoi qui ne détruisent pas ce que
l'éducation nationale a tenté de leur
inculquer tout au long de la journée
donc il ya comme ça il renverse un
renversement une fois une inversion
pardon de
de la responsabilité de et cette
stigmatisation je trouve pouces a déjà
un sentiment d'impuissance dans lequel
sont enfermés beaucoup de parents de
classes populaires qui habitent les
quartiers populaires en particulier et
qui peut amener parfois de la
résignation et en fait à ce que les
parents considèrent qu' il n'y a rien à
faire face à l'institution scolaire
notamment et face à la reproduction
sociale face aux inégalités
structurelles que subissent leurs
enfants mais ce que vous décrivez au
moins dans la première partie c'est
quelque chose qui a été partagé par
nombre de parents et pas forcément des
classes populaires issus de
l'immigration
du temps où les enfants appartenait à
leurs parents c'est à dire jusqu'au
19ème siècle les paysans par exemple en
vu d'un très mauvais oeil arriver les
les instituteurs les hussards noirs de
la république
les paysans étaient plutôt catholiques
pratiquants les hussards noirs c'était
l'école laïque et obligatoire il était
très très mal vue puis les îles on
voulait garder leurs enfants pour faire
les moissons alors que les actifs du
temps voulait garder les garder à
l'école il y avait le même rapport de
force et je pense que ce rapport de
force continue et pas seulement dans les
classes populaires il ya des tas de
parents qui ont l'impression que tout à
coup les autres les institutions le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a bien
plus d' influence sur sur le
développement que son enfant que que lui
même qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui fait la
différence à vos yeux fait immigrés sac
quand il s'agit d'une famille des
quartiers populaires et en plus par
exemple musulmane alors comme vous
l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure j'ai
écrit un livre qui ne s'appelle pas la
puissance des maires des classes
populaires ou des quartiers populaires
mais bien la puissance des maires pour
un sujet politique révolutionnaire donc
je ne parle pas d'une seule catégorie de
parents ou de mère l'entraîné pas
uniquement une entrée de classe 2 ou de
territoire c'est bien un sujet universel
donc j'ai bien conscience que cette
sentiment d'être dépossédés concerne
concerne l'ensemble des parents
l'ensemble l'ensemble des mères alors
moi je suis pas dans un rapport de force
vis-à-vis de l'éducation nationale est
ce à dire que ce que je pose dans le
livre c'est pas le fait de me sentir
dépossédé par une institution du simple
fait que il s'agit d'une institution
moi ce qui me gêne au sein de cette
institution l'école c'est que c'est
qu'elle l'ait inégalitaire et que petit
à petit elle tend à réduire le champ des
possibles de mes enfants de nos enfants
moi c'est ce qui me gêne en réalité dans
dans l'école donc voilà je cherche pas à
récupérer mes enfants et de la mainmise
comme ça de l'institution au contraire
moi j'invite tous les parents toutes les
mères à prendre une place plus grande au
sein de l'institution au sein de l'école
il s'agit pour moi au contraire
d'investir cet espace là et pour il y
imposer un rapport de force en vue d'un
système plus inégal plus égalitaire plus
juste qui respecte davantage la dignité
de nos enfants donc il s'agit bien pour
moi de deux de ses valeurs de défendre
des valeurs d'égalité de justice
de respect de la dignité humaine pour
moi c'est ça la question centrale en
réalité si je veux m'impliquer
politiquement pour mes enfants c'est
pour qu'ils puissent grandir ambitions
ambitieux curieux respectant leur
dignité qu'ils puissent réussir
qu'ils soient pas orienté petit à petit
vers un sou marché du travail en train
avec un travail qui va leur casser le
dos qui va casser leur santé mentale
c'est bien ça l'objectif voilà c'est pas
pour faire la bataille en soit avec avec
l'institution au fond l'éducation
nationale et et là-dessus effectivement
pour moi c'est un enjeu pardon et pour
moi c'est un enjeu donc universelle qui
doit concilier pourquoi je dois qui doit
concerner l'ensemble l'ensemble des
parents c'est en tant que parents et en
tant que maire en particulier puisque
c'est ce sujet politique là que j'ai
investi en tant que parents qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour nos enfants
comment on construit commencer le monde
en fait comment construire une autre
société
donc pour moi il s'agit d'avoir un
discours en rupture pour un changement
radical
une autre société plus juste plus
égalitaire le responsable c'est ça le
propos en réalité donc que l'institution
ait de la place ou pas peu importe ce
qui compte c'est bien cet objectif de
voir nos enfants à grandir heureux au
fond l'éducation nationale veut sortir
les enfants des foyers qui peuvent être
injuste ou violent injuste dans tous les
sens c'est à dire qu'ils puissent être
sectaire politiquement culturellement
religieusement et vous vous dites que
celle inverse au fond c'est le système
qui est souvent injuste et violent et
que ce sentiment d'impuissance devant
dans lequel on se trouve face à
l'éducation nationale mais aussi comme
vous l'avez dit au ministre de
l'intérieur aux médias à l'industrie y
compris à l'industrie du jouet à la
consommation ou au corps médical
au fond ce sentiment d'impuissance se
retrouve chez beaucoup de parents des
quartiers populaires
être beau être parents pour eux c'est
être stigmatisés c'est ce que vous ne
disiez au début de nos débuts de cette
conversation et vous donner un exemple
le livre est très bien décrit je dois
dire et vous donner un exemple qui est
très drôle enfin très drôle et en même
temps tragique c'est quand vous vous en
rendez vous voulez que
vous demandez à ce qu'on discute de la
possibilité que les enfants mangent
végétarien la cantine et c'est
impossible personne ne veut vous écouter
tout ça parce que vous êtes d'origine
arabe et que vous êtes musulmane et que
donc on vous souvent vous soupçonnent de
vouloir faire rentrer le communautarisme
à l'école de vouloir faire de l'entrisme
alors que tout ce que vous demandez
c'est qu'on discute pourquoi pas manger
végétarien à l'école parce qu'au fond
vous êtes plus écolo que les autres et
on sent bien à ce moment-là qu'il n'y a
plus de discussion possible on vous
renvoie constamment au fait que vous
êtes suspecte oui absolument
alors je ne pense pas juste pour revenir
sur le fait que c'est au sein de
l'institution que sont exercé
l'essentiel des violences
non je ne pense pas je suis féministe je
sais que c'est au sein de la famille
pour l'essentiel que s'exercent les
violences notamment physique sexuelle
gens parlent d'ailleurs dans le livre
jeudi qu' il s'agit aussi pour nous de
protéger nos enfants victimes de
pédocriminalité au sein de nos foyers
dans nos entourages puisque c'est là où
ils sont où ils subissent et agression
sexuelle donc il s'agit pas pour moi de
dire on subit plus de violence dans
l'institution plutôt que dans les
familles pas du tout mon propos c'est
plutôt de dire il y à des violences
partout dans tous les espaces sociaux
dans l'institution comme dans la famille
réapproprions-nous ce pouvoir de mer
pour protéger nos enfants
que ce soit au sein des foyers au sein
de word institutions oui alors
concernant cette histoire d'alternative
végétarienne qui est assez ubuesque
alors effectivement je la raconte dans
le livre dans une partie pour montrer à
quel point on a atteint un niveau de
casque hi 1 en fait je m'adresse à
plusieurs institutions pour demander
quelque chose de très simple je demande
à ce que ma fille puisse bénéficier d'un
repas équilibré à la cantine
même si elle ne mange pas de viande
voilà il ya une solution très simple
alors je raconte dans un livre que moi
la première fois que j'en ai entendu
parler en termes de dispositifs c'est
dans le propos d'yves jégo donkey un
député de droite
donc voilà c'est par un islamo
gauchistes c'est pas et on lui avait
fait quelque chose de très bien une
proposition de loi à l'assemblée pour
une alternative végétarienne à la
cantine et c'était très bien ça
répondait à des enjeux en termes
d'égalité de traitement de justice
sociale des enjeux est également en
vironnement taux de lutte contre la
maltraitance animale etc et donc moi je
suis arrivé avec ça et au lieu que au
lieu de deux de recevoir cette demande
cette revendication minimes
donc il s'agit que de la cantine s'est
passé à l'otan au lieu de la recevoir
comme une demande encore une fois de
d'égalité de justice sociale une demande
écologistes ça a été effectivement perçu
comme le cheval de troie de
l'islamisation de l'école une volonté de
ma part de d'imposer la charia alors je
demande est l'alternative végétarienne
on répondait halal parce qu'évidemment
ge avance masqué alors ont été mobilisés
toutes les représentations qu'on peut
avoir et sur les parents issus de
l'immigration postcoloniale les parents
musulmans les parents habitant les
quartiers populaires avec aussi l'idée
que nous donc par an issus de
l'immigration africaine
et puis deux classes populaires nous
n'aimons pas nos enfants
en réalité si nous devons le matin c'est
pas pour les défendre pour leur
bien-être pour leur bonheur c'est
forcément pour fomenter un plan
communautariste et séparatistes pour
faire du mal à la france
voilà c'est ce qui explique pourquoi
j'ai fait des enfants c'est vraiment
pour mener à bien ce projet donc je
disais ce dont j'ai besoin de toutes ses
représentations
il faut préciser que c'est dans une
municipalité de gauche 1 c'est pas une
municipalité d'extrêmement tout à fait
c'est une musicalité de gauche comme le
point de votre livre et c'est pour ça
qu'il est sous titré sur un plan
révolutionnaire c'est que vous pensez
que c'est l'union des maires au fond qui
peut qui doivent les maires doivent
s'unir pour permettre à leur enfant au
fond de réussir à l'école et de grandir
heureux et respecté
il y avoue donc citer un certain nombre
d'exemples on se souvient des fautes de
la place de mai en argentine qui venait
tourner en rond comme ça une fois par
semaine vous leur avez le dit qu'elle ne
devait pas rester immobile d'eau qu'elle
tournait en est pour demander comment ce
qui était arrivé à leur enfant ils
étaient disparus vous citez les les
folles de la place vendôme
ça c'est à marseille je crois les folles
de la place vendôme
alors à paris il ya des mères comme ça
de toute la région parisienne et de et
de marseille aussi de lyon voilà ça fait
qu'ils se mobilisent mais alors comment
alors il se trouve que vous avez créé le
front de mer vous aussi et que vous êtes
assez active
mais comment une fois que les maires se
mobilisent qu'elle ce ketch unis ce
qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent obtenir qu
est-ce que c'est quoi le but parce qu'au
fond tu es con vie en société
on sait bien que les pesanteurs de la
société influencent nos enfants pas
forcément dans le bon sens et internet
dont on parlait il ya un instant les
réseaux sociaux c'est la même chose
déjà c'est pas rien se mobiliser parce
que je dit ça comme si c'était une
première étape et qu'il s'agissait
simplement d'un détail maintenant
s'organiser dans notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans la classe
populaire de manière plus générale c'est
très très difficile
tout est fait pour entraver cette
organisation ce lien social
le simple fait déjà deux de pouvoir
circuler dans l'espace public c'est déjà
compliqué dans les quartiers populaires
il ya très peu de services publics
il ya très peu de tissu associatif ya
pas d'agora et puis on est très très
vite taxé comme comme comme je disais
tout à l'heure on est très vite taxé de
communautariste dès qu'on les 3,4 à
faire une petite réunion donc c'est très
très compliqué déjà de s'organiser
politiquement
ça renvoie toute la question de la
démocratie en france la question du
pouvoir le fait d'être dépossédés de du
pouvoir politique lorsqu'on est de
classes populaires et et de et de
quartiers populaires donc ça cette
première étape
là elle est déjà compliquée et en même
temps c'est beaucoup c'est à dire le
simple fait pour des maires de ne pas
rester isolé face à l'institution face
aux violences que subissent leurs
enfants le simple fait de se mettre à
deux trois quatre cinq six mois j'ai pu
paris mantes et le fait que ça pouvait
changer ça pouvait changer la vie du
quartier et la vie de la ville donc ce
n'est pas rien déjà de s'organiser
on sort de la solitude on sort des
injonctions paradoxales comme on le
disait tout à l'heure pour commencer on
sort de deux de ce sentiment
d'impuissance et de de cette résignation
dans laquelle on peut s'enfermer
justement parce que non on est isolé
donc déjà le fait de pouvoir se mettre à
quelques-unes déjà sacrés de la
solidarité ça crée une réappropriation
vraiment du pouvoir ensuite pourquoi
faire mais je pense que dans ces espaces
l'ajustement alors qu'ils existent déjà
il ya déjà des collectifs de mer qui
existent en france
alors vous vous parliez des fautes de la
place vendôme dans l'immigration et dans
la classe populaire
les mères qui se battent pour leurs
enfants et qui se battent politiquement
c'est quelque chose qui existe qui
datent pas d'hier qui existe depuis des
décennies donc vraiment la lutte qu'on
mène notamment en tant que fond de mer
s'inscrivant dans cette lutte là donc
c'est quelque chose qui existe est alors
je pense qu'il s'agit dans ces espaces
là de se poser la question de savoir de
quoi nous avons besoin de quoi ont
besoin nos enfants et quel monde nous
voulons pour eux je parlais tout à
l'heure de changement radical moi je
pose je pense qu'il faut dans ces
espaces la poser la question de ce qui
nous opprime et de tout ce qui nous
opprime
voilà le système capitaliste le système
racisme système patriarcal tout ce
système qui tend à hiérarchiser la
société ea ea et à réduire encore une
fois le champ des possibles de nos
enfants de la naissance jusqu'à leur
tombe
donc je pense que de partir de ça de
poser cette question la simple de quoi
nous avons besoin de quoi nos enfants
ont besoin pour grandir heureux
ambitieux curieux donc des choses très
très simple en réalité je pense que déjà
il y aura matière à matière à faire et
et c'est là je pense un vrai un vrai
projet politique
la puissance des mères c'est paru à la
découverte ces signes et fatima ou à ça
qu on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
fatima
on va parler d'abord avec daniel picouly
[Musique]
daniel picouly votre nouveau roman
s'intitule longtemps je me suis couché
de bonne heure chez albin michel
l'allusion à proust est clair mais votre
titre d'y faire subtilement de la
célèbre phrase qui ouvre la recherche du
temps perdu vous avez en effet écrit le
mot bonheur à la place de bonheur en
deux mots le mot bonheur en un mot à la
place de bonheur en deux mots pourquoi
parce que brosse m'a donné du bonheur
proust curieusement parce que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on le perçoit et plein de
bonheur parce que tout simplement c'est
un auteur libérateur par le blizzard
mais prouve c'est quelqu'un qui vous
apprend à 14 15 ans quand vous avez
envie d'écrire quand vous sentez que ça
va vous titiller il vous offre la
liberté
proust a pris toutes les libertés avec
la façon d'écrire à son époque
que ce soit dans le style dans la
construction dans la fabrication des
personnes à dans le rythme dans
l'enchaînement même dpam tout donc quand
vous lisez prose c'est premièrement ça
moi que j'ai vu en plus proche vous
apprends définitivement une deuxième
chose vous ne serez jamais proust
si vous n'avez pas son parcours si vous
n'êtes pas mais dans le milieu dans
lequel in et si vous n'avez pas la
religion qu'il a les origines la santé
la mauvaise santé qu'il a vous ne serez
jamais proulx c'est à dire que proosdij
fait cette espèce de cadeau empoisonné
je vous dirais bien va falloir que tu
fasses avec toi etc avec toi tu te
débrouilles pour être quelqu'un de
singulier qui regarde le monde de façon
singulier et hulot restitue au genre de
façon singulière et qui lors des bains
vous aussi vous avez la possibilité de
raconter le monde
votre vie ce que vous avez vécu et que
ça intéresse les autres parce que
fondamentalement proust il a rien vécu
d'extraordinaire il a eu une vie plutôt
terne et il en fait ce chef-d'oeuvre là
moi je trouve que ça ça donne de
l'espoir est là c'est ce roman se passe
dans votre cité de banlieue à orly en
c'est l'histoire d'un adolescent de 15
ans qui adore marcel proust c'est ta
note de l'essonne qui vous ressemble
comme deux gouttes os que tout vous est
arrivé
véritablement oui bien sûr bien sûr
parce que vous ne ferez jamais dire à un
romancier qui l'a fait il a joué avec la
liberté il l'a marqué sur la couverture
ya marqué roman noir qui s'est donné
tous les tous les droits
dans ce domaine là bien sûr que ça m'est
arrivé bien sûr que je suis de cette
cité hlm d'orly de ce collège
joliot-curie d'orly avec ses petits
gamins qu'ils rencontrent et parce que
j'ai pris au moins trois ou quatre pages
de notes pendant pendant l'interview
précédentes parce que enfin que si
beaucoup
retrouvez dans ce regard sur l'école
parce que ce livre est un hommage à
l'école est un hommage à ces enseignants
qui dans les années 60 quand il était
nommé dans ces collèges de banlieue se
sentait une mission c'est-à-dire son
étaient des sortes de hussards noirs
mais dans les collèges des des années 60
et que c'était des enseignants qui se
laissait pas prendre à notre apparence
turbulente assez sale gamin qu'on était
des chercheurs les emmerdes des gosses
qui rendait la vie impossible aux profs
et des jambes qui terrorisait le corps
enseignant le vendredi soir à 17h30
essayez d'imaginer 34 gamin de ce ces
objets quand vous êtes professeur de
littérature à 17h30 le vendredi il ne
pense qu'à une chose sortir et vous
passez le corps sur le corps s'il le
faut donc il faut une pédagogie c'est ce
qu'ils aient retenu en tant que prof
j'ai été prof pendant plus de 20 ans il
faut une pédagogie pour être capable
d'intéresser à la littérature à cette
heure-là
cette banque de mai le petit cénacle
e-coli les ans et demi écoulés que je le
faisais incroyable ce qui peut sembler
incroyable quand on lit votre roman
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en 1965 à orly orly
qui étaient des divisée entre les eaux
d'orly où il y avait les pavillons et
les bas d'orly où il y avait les cités
de banlieue vous étiez dans la cité
millions surnommé chicago on va voir des
images d'ailleurs parce que je suis allé
chercher voilà à quoi ça ressemblait je
crois la cité millions dans les années
on lisait proust en classe de troisième
et quand on y lisait pas proust on
lisait racine corneille
c'est quand même c'est un autre monde
bon racine corneille vous avez fait du
racing vous avez fait du corneille au
cola et chania pas de problème c'est au
programme prince n'était pas au
programme
face à ça c'est certain notre professeur
de lettres monsieur taquin en trousse tu
es le cours de littérature c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient capables d'en du racine
dans du corneille dans du molière de
vous mettre du proust et d'ailleurs
comme il avait une sainte terreur de
l'inspection surprise il avait toujours
mis un vers de racine sur le tableau en
cas où un inspecteur entre et nous on
était complètement complice de ça on
aurait sorti notre bérénice et on aurait
suivi le vert en question thank hat va
cesser c'est ce cet homme a réussi à
nous passionner avec trousses alors que
proust n'était pas au programme et
rattachait tout ce qu'il y avait dans
proust procès une comédie humaine
soyons clairs c'est une comédie humaine
vous faites balzac zola vous faites
proust sauf que c'est une comédie
humaine dans le faubourg saint-germain
et dans certaines dans certains milieux
sociale mais il ya autant de bêtises de
vantardise de lâcheté de grandeur dans
le ce milieu là que dans tous les autres
milieux et c'est ça aussi que proust
vous apprend la bêtise est une des
choses les mieux répartie au monde et
c'est intéressant ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire c'est que les hanches
les grands écrivains nous raconte
quelque chose qui était beau et vrai
quand il était là mais ça reste beau et
vrai un siècle plus tard et est ce qui
était beau et vrai pour pour proust dans
le milieu qu'il fréquentait au fond on
peut le retrouver dans d'autres milieux
y compris 60 ans de stars à la cité
millions et votre jeune héros vous en
l'occurrence pratique l'art de l'art
transposition au fond ils les gardiens
de l'immeuble
ce sont les verdurin les charlus c'est
un égoutier antilles et etc etc
et lui il a il est amoureux d'une fille
c'est forcément albertine c'est
albertine disparue rappelle que pro ce
prix consacre à peu près 3000 pages dont
la recherche du temps perdu
donc il ya de quoi effectivement se
documente est un catalogue d'expérience
que dont profite votre héros et qui va
appliquer dans sa cité de banlieue et ça
marche
oui mais c'est vrai que c'est un
catalogue d'expérience parce que prouve
qu est ce qui vous dit
en gros si on résume écoute dans la vie
y compris les histoires d'amour ça va
bien commencer ça va même prendre un
certain optimum mais ça va mal se finir
il met trois mille pages c'est un
spoiler pour 11 c'est quelqu'un qui vous
spolie la vie si vous le prenez comme ça
mais comme il s'adresse à des mômes de
14 15 ans des adolescents
qu'est ce qu'ils disent face à cette
espèce d'illusion cap rousse de
comprendre la vie mieux que nous puis tu
me peut-être pour toi mais moi
certainement pas c'est à dire que à
l'adolescence on prend proust et puis
pour lui de démontrer aux camarades
français nous on va échapper à cette
espèce de fatalité
j'ai une fatalité et jade et romanesque
et qui chez nous et apparaît comme une
fatalité sociale parce que la petite
albertine bien évidemment elle est
plutôt des ondes orly et moi plutôt
débat c'est à dire que à à 15 ans déjà
je vis cette fracture entre le haut et
le bas
moi je sais que je suis du bas elle ne
sait pas encore que qu'elle est due aux
parce qu'elle trouve ça complètement
normal mais c'est ce qu'ils font là
mentalement dès le départ vanu fracturé
en plus vieux j'ai une allure d'un petit
gamin qui me pends très classe moyenne
des beaux quartiers bon et ça ça va me
c'est peut-être le premier la première
fois le premier livre ou jeu où je joue
je parle de ce sentiment que j'appelle
souvent devine qui vient dîner ce soir
c'est à dire une vie où vous interrogez
quand vous allez être invité dans la
famille de la jeune fille dont vous êtes
amoureux
qu'est ce qui va se passer et ça c'est
quelque chose qui qui vous poursuit ou
qui vous suit toute la vie et ça je le
découvre à 14 15 ans je sais en une
fraction de seconde que cette albertine
m'a regardé je veux croire que c'est
amoureusement parce que comme ça ça me
fait ça va me faire vivre 230 pages mais
je sais au fond de moi que cette
histoire est impossible et c'est une
histoire possible au sens aux prises dix
à proposer albertine j'ai écrit
peut-être 3000 pages sur une femme une
jeune fille qui en fait n'était pas fait
pour moi et c'est ce qu'a basque apprend
procès complet dans la vie met en
mouvement par deux grossières erreurs
qu'elle soit sentimentale ou thé soit
idéologique est cependant nous mener
quelque part où on se sent bien au bout
de toutes les péripéties et c'est ça
aussi une trousse curieusement et comme
pro 6 à u 100e anniversaire du goncourt
et que j'ai assisté à des tas de
conférences d'entretien j'ai parlé et je
ne retrouvais pas mon trousses j'ai
voulu faire vivre mon proust c'est à
dire cette réappropriation que chacun
peut pratiquer de procme que chacun peut
pratiquer sur n'importe quelle oeuvre et
je me suis toujours battue j'ai jamais
compris que certains intellectuels
certes veulent à tout prix que proust il
soit à eux parce que c'est un génie et
un génie ne peut venir que de cette
classe supérieure d'intellectuels ou de
champs cultivés et bien le génie peut
bien venir d'où il veut et on a nous le
droit de l'amener ouvre et rouge
l'emmener dans ma cité mais je vous
assure qu'ils s'y sentait bien moi alors
question par rapport à tout ce qu'il
nous a dit fatima wassa qu il ya un
instant et je sais qu'elle elle vous
écoute ça beaucoup
ce que ce que décrit fatima c'est très
différent de ce que vous avez connu vous
dans votre site et daniel picouly votre
mère n'était pas n'était pas dans la
situation se trouvent des maires comme
fatima ouais ça qu'aujourd'hui alors ce
que ce que j'ai ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimée dans ce qu'il ya dans ce qui a été
dit bien évidemment ma mère a fait
treize enfants
je suis on le 11e d'une famille de 13
mais j'ai plus de seurre que des frères
donc j'ai été élevée dans les fermes ma
famille c'est un gynécée la puissance
c'est celle c'est celle des femmes mais
moi ce qui me gêne le plus dans l'école
beaucoup de choses me gêne d'abord un la
première question c'est pourquoi la
dégradation c'est à dire cette espèce de
dérive des continents à l'intérieur de
l'école ces inégalités pourquoi elle
perdure depuis 40 ans tout système
politique confondue en depuis 40 ans
pourquoi à qui profite le crime
comment se fait-il que quelque chose qui
est évident à tous et pour tous perdure
qui bénéficie justement de cette
injustice
les deux catégories sociales ses de la
sociologie tout simplement bête qui
profitent de l'école sont les fils de
cadres et les fils d'enseignants
pourquoi parce que déjà l'école il faut
savoir comment ça fonctionne
l'école c'est un mode d'emploi de plus
en plus sophistiqués et la chose que moi
je reproche aussi à l'école c'est
d'avoir rompu le lien entre les
générations ma mère n'avait que le
certificat d'études mais pouvait me
faire réciter mais le son pendant assez
longtemps
elle m'a fait réciter mais le son le coc
vida a pris aux gens que dès la 4e mais
bien avant on était complètement largués
dans les connaissances qu'il y avait et
qu'on voulait à j'allais dire pas imposé
mais en tout cas diffusé à nos enfants
l'école c'est sophistiqué pour être de
plus en plus la propriété de ceux qui
savent manier l'école et qui ont les
connaissances pour manier l'école ce qui
quand ils ne peuvent pas parce qu'il ya
aussi ces sociologique aussi on dit que
le niveau d'un enfant dans son avenir
est directement liée au niveau d'étude
de sa mère parce que c'est elle qui
élève
c'est elle qui va guider c'est elle qui
va s'y reconnaître dans le système
scolaire celle qui va se bagarrer
ma mère avait aussi cette attitude de
dragon ben quand ça n'allait pas ma mère
a dit je vais me déranger quand elle
disait je vais me dérange et ça veut
dire qu'à la belle met son chapeau et
partir avec son parapluie
c'est à dire qu elle n'annulaient pas se
laisser
imposer ce que l'école parce que c'est
mes gosses à 10 heures ce sont mes
gosses bon et cette simple petite
formule la mettait en mouvement compte
toutes les inégalités et bien évidemment
que ce qui se passe dans l'école c'est
une mise en situation
sournoise sournois c'est à dire à
travers la difficulté des programmes à
travers cette incapacité pour les
parents de suivre leurs enfants sauf à
leur donner des cours de ceux-ci décor
de cela c'est à dire d'avoir les moyens
de le faire c'est ça qui me gêne le plus
parce que tout le monde sait et si je
suis ministre de l'éducation nationale
je ne vais pas provoquer de révolution
qui vont mettre les enfants dans les
rues les lycéens les collégiens ou les
étudiants passent quand on dit souvent
les jeunes c'est comme le dentifrice une
fois qu'ils sont sortis du tube on
n'arrive pas à les en sortir
et c est une hantise de la part d' donc
il vaut mieux faire les choses très
sournoisement à travers des programmes
après la difficulté à travers cette
espèce de professionnalisation que les
parents doivent avoir pour comprendre
parcours super tout ça mais c'est c'est
un truc un sens et qu'ils faillent à ce
point comprendre eq stratège du système
éducatif français pour donner une chance
à ces enfants d'aller là où ils veulent
et là où ils seront le mieux c'est c'est
anti démocratique tout simplement
et à partir de là bien évidemment
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de 2,2
d'énergie se met en mouvement pour
contrecarrer ça mais à la base si on ne
réfléchit pas à ce que c'est une école
du pouvoir qui défend le pouvoir de
certains on a des chances de se laisser
embarquer vers autre chose que ce que je
crois moi pourrait être efficace
fatima way sac vous avez entendu daniel
picouly une réaction
oui moi je moi je suis d'accord avec
tout ce qui vient d'être dit évidemment
il faut il faut et pour aller un petit
peu plus loin encore il faut changer
d'école faut changer de système faire en
sorte que ce que ça devienne le lieu
d'émancipation qui km et pas simplement
un lieu de reproduction sociale et je
pense que pour changer de système il
faut faut être collectif faut être
solidaire et
et avec les enseignants parce que je
connais beaucoup d'enseignants qui sont
et d'enseignantes qui sont désemparés
dire que qui sont mus par part voilà le
cet objectif de 2 d'égalité de justice
sociale etc etc mais qui sont dans un
système qui est par définition
structurellement inégalitaire donc je
pense que si les parents pouvaient se
joindre aux enseignants dans une lutte
pour remettre en question ce système est
payant en construire un autre basé sur
des enjeux de encore une fois d'égalité
de justice de respect de la dignité
humaine de bienveillance vis-à-vis des
les enfants je pense qu'on que déjà
voilà le simple fait de se mettre en
mouvement
ce serait déjà ce serait déjà évidemment
avancé alors ce que je peux dire aussi
c'est que dans mon livre j'insiste aussi
sur ce que ce que peut faire ce que
peuvent faire les parents ce que peuvent
faire les maires en particulier
vis-à-vis de leurs enfants parce
qu'évidemment il s'agit de dire que nous
avons une responsabilité aussi dans
l'éducation il n'y a pas que l'école qui
éduque nos enfants nous avons l'empiré
et pleines responsabilités en matière
d'éducation et de transmission vis-à-vis
de nos enfants ce que je dis aussi c'est
que il faut penser une autre parentalité
qui soit basée non pas sur une
transmission d'identité figé vis-à-vis
nos enfants mais sur la transmission
d'une capacité à ne pas se résigner et
là dessus on a dans notre histoire dans
nos histoires dans nos mémoire des
luttes glorieuse d'élus de l'immigration
des luttes de la classe ouvrière des
luttes que l'on peut transmettre à nos
enfants nos langues maternelles nos
cultures et c est alors qu en tant que
tel il s'agit pas encore une fois de
transmettre d identité pour des
identités mais vraiment cette capacité à
ne pas se résigner et cette capacité qui
va permettre à nos enfants dès le plus
jeune âge de ne pas pas de pouvoir
affronter en fait le système le système
d'oppression le système inégalités et
fige agence quelque chose aussi en tant
que parent a travaillé et proust dans ce
domaine c'est pas mal aussi
un dernier mot très vite daniel picouly
parce que j'ai vincent cuvellier oui non
parce que tout à l'heure j'ai entendu le
mot j'ai entendu le mot
j'ai entendu le mot laxisme et je
voudrais faire référence à quelque chose
d'actualité monsieur darmanin quand il a
parlé de de la drogue et des amendes que
l'on à aller donner aux gens qui sont
consommateurs de il a ajouté dans sa
phrase quelque chose qui est un lapsus
extraordinaires y compris dans les beaux
quartiers y compris dans les beaux
quartiers
cela veut dire quoi que avant non avant
non on avait un certain laxisme à
l'égard des beaux quartiers qu'on
traitait pas de la même façon un petit
dealer ou un petit consommateur de
banlieue et des beaux quartiers
j'ai trouvé dans cette phrase un très
joli lapsus longtemps je me suis couché
de bonne heure c'est le titre du nouveau
roman de daniel picouly qui vient de
paraître chez albin michel
[Musique]
vincent cuvellier vous êtes auteur pour
la jeunesse la première oeuvre de vous
dont j'ai eu connaissance c'était la
pétition vous aviez publié pour
interdire les pétitions c'était après
une pétition justement contre les
pipelettes une série bande dessinée
accusé de sexisme par des féministes ce
qui avait provoqué la suspension par
l'éditeur et la décision de la
dessinatrice d'arrêter carrément la
série vous a viré pour lui par une
pétition pour interdire les pétitions
sur le thème non à l'interdiction des
livres qui nous déplaisent
et puis à la suite de quoi vous aussi
vous avez été inquiété c'était pour
votre livre la guerre des bisous
et là une dessinatrice d'ailleurs au nom
du féminisme vous avez attaqué vous avez
dit que c'était en fait de l'appel à
l'agression sexuelle voire de l'appel au
violent que de d'aller faire un bisou
comme ça à quelqu'un qui n'était pas
prévenu est-ce que ça s'est durcie dans
les infos pour jeunesse est ce que tout
le monde fait attention à tout le monde
en ce moment
alors je sais pas si ça s'est durci mais
en tout cas dans les livres pour enfants
c'est clairement pris pour cible parce
qu'on met beaucoup de choses dans les
livres pour enfants enfin rendre les
enseignants les auteurs mettent beaucoup
de choses à partir du moment où on sait
des livres qui sont destinés aux enfants
ils dégagent une charge que peut-être
les autres livres n'ont pas toujours
on veut qu'il soit moralement
irréprochable on veut qu'ils soient bien
écrit on veut qu'il y ait un gros mot
c'est tout un ensemble de charges de
cons mais dans la littérature jeunesse
en fait dans le livre dont vous parliez
la manière des bisous je précise que
bisous surprise c'était la petite fille
de 5,6 en maternelle qui faisait sur
l'apathie garçons de 5 6 ans ça en dit
long
vous continuez évidemment les livres
pour enfants le dernier vient de
paraître
toujours chez gallimard un il s'intitule
la traversée des animaux c'est une
histoire d'animaux qui ça se passe au
19e siècle
à moscou il s'enfuit d'un zoo et voilà
c'est toute une aventure mais ce n est
pas pour ce livre là que je vous ai
invités bien qu'il soit très joli c'est
c'est pour le plus mauvais livres du
monde qui vient de paraître chez nathan
jeunesse la ccl qui la cible s'est
laissé les post ado la cible alors les
plus motivés de collection se sont
déliées qui sont destinés aux enfants
s'ils n'aiment pas lire aux jeunes qui
n'aiment pas bien que toi aux ados et
aux adultes
si l'intérieur donc de votre héros qui
n'aiment pas lire donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils n'aiment pas lire votre héros
c'est un peu plus compliqué actions mon
héros on va se rendre compte qu'ils
veulent bien écrit en fait
bon c'est un petit peu coopératif tiens
vous en doutez ou quoi moi j'ai commencé
à injecter l'école très jeune
vite on revient dans le sujet de tout à
l'heure j'ai arrêté l'école à 16 ans en
troisième après avoir redoublé deux fois
et j'ai publié mon premier livre à 17
ans dans le cadre d'un au prix d un
écrivain à l'époque donc j'ai eu le truc
bizarre deux à la fois d'être mauvaise
élève est à la fois de commencer à
devenir écrivain très jeune et mon
personnage est un peu confronté à ça il
part en part au voyage eut fait pas
vraiment une fugue me voyez sur les
petits fruits ce pas trop à faire nos
qui prend le train un petit peu par
hasard comme faire moi quand vous avez
un 18 ans et son portable ne marche pas
c'est pour ça que je perds mes
téléphones portables tout à l'heure
parce que s'il y avait eu un téléphone
portable dans ce livre on histoire
n'aurait pas pu avoir lieu en fait et
donc il va dans une boîte à livres et il
prend le soliste qui a et commence à
venir dans notre être ça absolument
terrible c'est une écriture très
boursouflé très violement j'étais à
fondre avec un la capture je me suis
amusé à écrire un mauvais livre ce qui
s'avérait très mauvais les libraires oui
bon autant y aller à fond vous n'allez
pas vous n'avez pas eu voilà je n'allais
pas faire dans le détail donc surtout un
livre très très prétentieux moment-là
personne se regarde écrire est en fait
ce personnage paul va rencontrer
l'auteur du livre et du trap par le
contrôleur parce qu'il appelle billets y
descend la première gare il va au buffet
de la gare et au buffet de la gare
il tombe sur les l'auteur de ce très
très mauvais livre qui tout ému de
rencontrer ses lecteurs l'invite ensuite
à rester chez lui et il accepte pour une
seule raison c'est qu'il se trouve que
la fille de l'auteur et canon et quel
sondage et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il va suivre est la question que je me
suis posée j'ai trouvé ce livre très
drôle
je me suis dit pour dans une collection
comme celle ci qui s'adresse à des des
adolescents qui n'aiment pas lire au
départ
alors c'est quoi les règles j'ai
l'imposé il faut que ce soit court les
chapitres doivent être courts le récit
doit être court mais pour en revenir au
problème de la pétition de tout à
l'heure est ce qu'un à d'autres est ce
qu il faut faire attention parce que par
un moment dans ce livre il décrit son
érection par exemple il ya pas de limite
là on peut faire ce qu'on veut on peut
dire ce que l'on veut
oui je vois pas pourquoi il aurait fini
sa vie ni celle de la décence ou non
mais pas en fait moi je perdrais facile
que quand on écrit pour les jeunes on
écrit pour des raisons pour tous qui
j'aurai pourquoi on s'empresserait de
caler sujet alors évidemment on fait un
petit peu attention c'est logique a
donné c'est un idiot non plus mais je ne
vois pas pourquoi on parlera pas
certaines choses à des jeunes en fait
aucune raison ne sont pas en sucre nous
non plus tout va bien vous même ayant
été attaqué sur les gars du bisou est ce
que vous faites plus particulièrement
attention aujourd'hui on dit que les
services juridiques des maisons
d'édition sont constamment sur la brèche
qui sait s'attendent toujours aux
attaques aux dénonciations
c'est votre cas non pas forcément mais
parce que parce que je ne souhaite pas
en fait c'est une démarche aussi de
faire attention c'est compliqué de
savoir comment se défendre contre ces
gens là j'ai regardé votre émission hier
sur la grande scène culture c'est
compliqué de savoir comment comment
répondre à ces attaques
il croit que la première réponse c'est
de continuer comme avant en fait de deux
pas de patiner de katie moore et le cas
avoir peur de rien toujours la peur
d'eux
le faire tomber dessus et ses essais
c'est pas simple moi quand il ya eu le
petit problème sur la guerre des bisous
franchement ce n'était pas simple c'est
pas évident je me suis posé la question
de savoir est ce que faisait le dos rond
est ce que je rentrais dedans bon j'ai
décidé de rentrer dedans de prendre
l'initiative
mais c'est évident c'est fatigant c'est
pas drôle on lit des insultes que sur
soi rien de brou nasa mais en même temps
voilà je pense que là la liberté
d'écriture est tellement liée aux
métiers des clients
moi en tout cas je sens que j'ai pas le
choix je sens que justement si je suis
parti dans cette profession a après
avoir complètement raté mon parcours
scolaire
c'est justement parce que sam offrait un
endroit pour votre livre combat musée
pour être voilà pour dire ce que je
voulais c'est très important pour moi le
dire ce que je voulais je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils ont encore des espaces
or il se trouve que votre héros écrit
des trucs comme il dit et et à un moment
il est il comme il a beaucoup
d'imagination et ils imaginent qu'ils
pourraient ils s'inventent une histoire
assassiner les uns après les autres tous
les élèves de sa classe pour pour à la
fa être le premier c'est le genre de
truc qui si on n'a pas lu le livre on
sait on ne comprend pas que c'est drôle
que c'était écrit avec humour comme
quelque chose qui peut traverser les
l'imagination d'un garçon de cet âge et
si on le raconte sur les réseaux sociaux
pour vous dénoncez on peut dire que vous
faites l'apologie des meurtres de masse
et dieu sait s'il y en a eus aux états
unis ou ailleurs et que c'est horrible
et qu'on devrait pas vous appris mais on
sait bien c'est là où je me dis tout
peut être mal interprété et est pour
cette raison que rien ne pourrait être
écrit si on si on commençait se
surveiller soi même ma réaction à la
pétition que vous rappeliez tout à
l'heure elle est partie de quelque chose
de très simple
il y avait une copine à moi qui est
illustratrice très sympa qui avait signé
la pétition pour interdire le livre
d'eli plaît de vous parliez et moi j'ai
envoyé un petit mot pour les lire les
intentions tu sais que ça peut nous
arriver à n'importe qui en fait et les
mois je pense que je peux prendre
n'importe quel livre pour enfants on va
rester dans mon domaine écrit cette
année et trouver quelque chose de
problématique qui peut donner lieu à une
pétition ils interdisent nantes
addiction ensuite persuader en tout cas
mes livres ils ont sont touchés c'est
évident parce que tout peut être mal
interprété c'est la paranoïa appliqué à
la littérature le plus beau des livres
du monde c'est donc signé vincent
cuvellier ça vient de paraître chez
nathan merci va sans merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]